wenn wir über risiko und nutzen sprechen
dann geht es irgendwann auch ums geld
natürlich sie konnten ihren sport nicht
ausüben sie haben arztkosten gehabt
medikamentenkosten usw wer zahlt die ihn
bisher
bisher übernehme ich den großteil selber
also sind halt alles nicht anerkannte
behandlungen ich hab ne immunglobulin
therapie bekommen für 3000 euro die also
es ist ja keine anerkannte erkrankungen
demnach auch keine anerkannte behandlung
und mir wurde halt gesagt das ist alles
jetzt test und wenn du das machen willst
dann freiwillig sagen sie ja frau habe
mit würden sie unterstützen er sich
sollten sie also ich bin keine
medizinrecht lerin und deswegen betreue
ich solche fälle auch nicht so insofern
würde ich nicht machen weil das auch
noch bitte die kollegen und kolleginnen
machen die die deine experte aber wenn
sie das hören wollte eine gigantische
kostenlawine auf uns zu die unternehmen
das wissen wir übernehmen die kosten
nicht die sind von der haftung in dem
fall ja ausgeschlossen durch die
verträge die geschlossen wurden das
heißt auf uns alle auf uns steuerzahler
rollte eine riesige kostenlawine also
juristisch wird das problem vor allem
seien die kausalität nachzuweisen also
insofern und das ist gleichzeitig auch
das problem was betroffene haben ja weil
wahrscheinlich wird am ende des tages
nicht viele kosten das heißt verputzen
wird offiziell nicht geglaubt werde das
ist es wird so sein keine frage des
glaubens weil es auch keine frage ist ob
das jetzt eine impfreaktion ist oder
nicht aber die couch fragen die eltern
mensch ist desto eher sich jünger und
weniger vor erkrankt desto eher aber
eigentlich kosten die kosten aufzukommen
sind teil dieser naturkatastrophe
pandemie wenn wir jetzt auch andersrum
denkt wenn es keinen impfstoff gegeben
hätte dann wären die kosten unter
umständen viel höher ich klar das
problem ist nur dass frau bozen bisher
auf den kosten alleine sitzen bleibt und
wir an dem tisch einmal thematisieren
wollen wird es so bleiben oder gibt es
irgendjemand netterweise in der politik
der sich darum kümmern ich denke wir und
wir müssen das thema angehen denn das
ist ja eben nicht nur frauen putzen das
betrifft ja ganz viele menschen
ganz offensichtlich und krone hat ja
eben hinterlässt er sehr viele leute
leute die mit
von longoria betroffen sind die ihr
gewerk nicht mehr ausüben können die
berufsunfähig werden und die genau die
gleichen probleme mit der kausalität
haben wer ist dann schon in der
glücklichen situation zum beispiel sich
während der arbeit infiziert zu haben so
dass die berufsgenossenschaft im
augenblick seinen seinen heilungsprozess
ohr sein seine genesung begleitet wer
von uns ist ja es gibt ja auch mediziner
die erkranken und die vorher einen sehr
hohen lebensstandard hatten und jetzt
seit ihrer infektion eben nur noch auf
dem letzten loch das heißt die politik
gilt aber auch damit man himmel die
kosten nicht tragen muss tut alles dafür
dass man eben nicht nachweisen kann dass
watson ist dann so ist das soll ich auf
meine frage ja genau also ich habe das
auch so verstanden wohlwollend als frage
denn ich denke es gibt sachen für die
die politik zuständig ist und dann gibt
es gott sei dank in unserem rechtsstaat
mit den verschiedenen zuständigkeiten
eben die gewaltenteilung und ich bin
eigentlich sehr froh denn genau wenn
jemand in diesen weg geht und dagegen
klagt und er sich um die kausalität
kümmern organe der rechtspflege ihn
vertreten dann bekommen wir ja
ergebnisse dann tatsächlich himmel habe
dazu gehört auch eine politik die den
den weg insoweit ebnet dass das kein
tabu ist denn gerichte richterinnen und
richter sind menschen und die lassen
sich auch beeinflussen von einem
narrativ der fahrer ist das so wir also
entschuldigungen ja gerade und
einrichtungen
in der korona pandemie uns doch einen
aus gerettet denn oft genug wir haben
jetzt die politik oft genug kritisiert
ja und sie haben einige sachen ganz gut
gemeistert und bei anderen nicht und wo
sind diese fälle dann gelandet
massnahmen nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz
bei den richterinnen und richtern in
diesem land und an der fülle der
entscheidung die ergangen sind und wo
daneben auch die kläger recht bekommen
haben sehen wir doch das ist ja das
kaiserreich denen der freie richter eben
durchaus seinen job macht und darüber
können wir alle sehr froh sein dann
wären wir wirklich in einer corona
diktatur dann wäre die sache nicht bei
gericht gelandet dann werden die leute
wirklich mundtot ich möchte sagen wir
sind doch hier in dieser situation dass
wir alle hier unsere auffassung
vertreten können wir kriegen alle
hinterher drescher aber niemand sagt
dass dass das was ich äußere
unwidersprochen bleiben muss so ist doch
unsere gesellschaft
zurück die die frage war mit blick auf
den fall von frau kurzen die erkrankung
von verputzen ob sie überhaupt hilfe
bekommt ob es überhaupt herzige
überhaupt anwälte gibt die sich des
themas annehmen oder ob die nicht sofort
das problem haben diese schmutzige ecke
in diese querdenker ecke da will ich
nicht rein das ist mir zu heikel also
bei den ärzten und ärztinnen scheint das
ja so zu sein also was man von
betroffenen hört da werden sie sind
wahrscheinlich auch passiert werden sie
noch was dazu sagen so ich finde erst
mal fatal das bis heute keine außer eben
jetzt marburg die natürlich jetzt in dem
alter sind in einer ambulanz kenner
ärzte die sich gekümmert keinerlei
anlaufstellen gibt weil mit so einer
riesen werbekampagne zumindest dachte
ich das damals dass das halt mit
einhergeht für sich selber betroffen war
und ich war also letztes jahr hat es bei
mir kein arzt gemeldet also ich war beim
thema und ärzten und das ich glaube dass
das erste mal gemeldet wurde ich kann es
auch nicht sagen als ich in marburg war
und das war im april und davon habe ich
auch nur erfahrung weil ich mich mit
anderen betroffenen austauschen nicht
weil irgendwie das bundesministerium für
gesundheit auf facebook oder soll alvaro
diesen unmut nimmt frau preißler mit in
ihrem wahlkreis zu ihrer politik zur fdp
zu ihren ministern und die nimmt auch
herr stöhr mit nach berlin zu den
sachverständigen geht diskutieren gleich
weiter über neue maßnahmen über die die
politik im moment ganz aktiv diskutiert
zum beispiel über die wiedereinführung
der masken pflicht von oktober bis
ostern also es halbe jahr der unmut ist
riesengroß wie unter anderem bei einem
großen schlager star den sie gleich in
dieser sendung genau mit diesem unmut
erleben
[Musik]